- Um...
(slurping)
- It was too much.
(both laugh)
(energetic music)
- [Voiceover] Bananinha.
- They shouldn't be able
to do this with a dessert.
This is a bad sign.
- What is better than one banana?
Three bananas in one.
- I feel like they invented this in NASA.
- It tastes like, really, really,
really dense banana bread.
- Oh that's good.
- Excuse me, please explain how
you got three bananas in here.
- [Voiceover] Bala de Coco.
- Coc Festa.
(laughs)
- Ooh, it sounds like a coconut party.
- Whoo, what do we got here?
Oh god.
- They're like giant dinner mints.
- I don't really like
coconut flavor d candy,
but this is pretty good.
- I've never seen a candy before that like
warns you on the bag explicitly
like, brush your teeth.
- These are good for
your teeth apparently.
I'm going to assume that's what
that little happy tooth
means on the back of this.
- Literally don't taste
any coconut whatsoever.
- None.
- Like if you didn't
have coconut on the bag, that's fine.
- This is, it's sweeter than sugar.
- [Voiceover] Bis.
- It's uh, you know.
A biscuit but,
- Bis.
- no time, Bis.
- Bis?
- I'm all up in this Bis.
- That's better than a Kit Kat.
- I do like the wafers though,
because I'm a texture person
and I like the crunch.
The crisp.
- Mm, hmm, the crunch is nice.
- That is delicious.
- Yeah.
This is like just wafers with chocolate.
- Yeah man.
- There is nothing you
can (beep) up with this.
- [Voiceover] 7Belo.
- Seven Beyo.
Or Belo.
- I can do this.
- I have given up at this point.
- Yeah.
- It says Framboesa, which
I think means strawberry.
- Looks like plastic, so it's
probably pretty good candy.
- One, two, one.
- Three, two, one.
- I like it.
- Game over.
- This is gonna pull out my cavities.
- I think it could take a bullet.
- Like just the right
amount of artificial.
- It's very chewy.
- It has some extra to it, it
has like a little samba to it.
- What?
- You know what I'm saying,
a little some of this.
That's how they do it.
It's nice, eating your amazing
candy Brazil, and um...
- And now, I feel like I
could conquer the world
with all this sugar
running through my veins.